you
in that the most mundane level classes
are being logged if you like on the
internet you exchange homework readings
PDFs so the way we engage with each
other is done through this third medium
but collaborative platforms are also
going towards information technology in
the old days I would have to fly many
miles in order to meet with people I get
onto my computer I dial into WebEx and a
variety of people consultants clients
and everybody can see on the very page
that I put post on the on the Internet
and we begin to draw together on it what
is interesting about this is that it
instigates a relationship between images
and words that often was overlooked
because everybody gets to participate on
in that drawing platform and in that way
in a much more compressed amount of time
you get to have the knowledge that you
borrow let's say from the engineers from
the various other consultants from
programming groups and so forth to
compress all of that into the medium of
architecture which altom utley specifies
things on a document the document is
essentially a you know a series of drawn
documents in a series of specifications
so the interactive abilities of
information technology actually do
change the way you work
the most immediate thing that has
impacted our generation in the last 20
years is the way that we built if mass
production brought to the world the
possibility of rapid expansion of
modularity repetition digitization has
brought about the possibility of
customization the idea that diversity
difference individuality can be engaged
with the same ease as mass production
the question of its relevance the
question of its engagement in different
venues is still you know up in the air
but certainly the way we produce now is
different as a result of that also
because of the control it has given
designers this has legal ramifications
because the traditional relationship
between clients contractors and
designers has shifted designers no
longer need to merely submit their
drawings to contractors to get bids or
to get to get to know what the means and
methods of its production are they get
to be a higher stakeholder in the
determination of that form and how its
produced that makes a huge difference
certainly I'm not certain about how
everybody else works but to be honest
with you but you can see it all around
you
you can't imagine a practice like Frank
Gehry without seeing the hurdles he must
have gone through in order to convince
the sheet metal industry to build the
way they have done for him they have a
they probably had a set of techniques
which were germane to their industry but
Gary had to cultivate a different level
of dialogue with them not only for
reasons of liability but for reasons of
instrument instrumentalization and and
that generation gave us a next
generation of work that we are now
seeing through the work of you know
Farshid Moussavi and Alejandro Zyra
Paulo in Yokohama and
AHIMA in-laws on all of these buildings
the EPFL the and the yokohama port are
the result of I think a very close
tinkering between enterprises that are
spatial material engineering and
environmental and I can't think that you
can arrive at those places without a
closed synchronicity if you like between
the different disciplines